the hard thing are teens and early 20s
people and my parents my parents are the
hard ones Jennifer Garner just wants her
parents to stay home on Thursday the
actress video chatted with Jimmy Fallon
for his at-home version of The Tonight
Show where she expressed her frustration
with her mom and dad William and
Patricia the hard thing are teens and
early 20s people and my parents my
parents are the hard ones I'm their dad
mom the world is shut down to keep you
guys safe and they're like we think
we're gonna go to Sam's warehouse stay
home the 47 year old added that her
three kids with x-band a flick
fourteen-year-old violet 11 year old
Serafina and eight year old Samuel have
actually been pretty great during the
quarantine I think I have the perfect
age kids for this because they're big
enough to understand and to have the
conversations like we're built for
challenge we can do this we're a tough
team let's learn about a vacuum cleaner
they're not so big that they're just
like well I don't care a minute goes Jen
also opened up about the two projects
she's working on during the quarantine
hello
and I'm Jen and we're here to tell you
about save with stories Jen and Amy
Adams partnered up with Save the
Children and started the hashtag save
the stories campaign where they have
different Stu labs reading children's
books and asking people to donate money
to children who are going hungry
due to school closures people I have
never met before our community is just
so generous and so just how can I help
what can I do and we are getting rights
to books so thank you for loaning us
sewers and I would read other ones to
let me know I'm down oh my gosh really
oh yeah would you read everything is
mama I love that book so much
tuesdaya that will do it right now I
cannot wait to do that Hey not only has
Jenny pitched in this is baby by Jimmy
Fallon that's me the show has Reese
Witherspoon
and Jennifer called me and said hey
would you read some stories to some kids
and I was like yeah I want to tell
stories
natalie portman I'm gonna read is your
mama a llama brie Larson the warthog
started waltzing and the Rhinos rock and
rolled and Ellen DeGeneres we first saw
this house when we were invited over to
watch American Idol just to name a few
Jim and Tim had just started to relax in
the sandy little house when the big bad
shark came knocking at the door Jen also
talked about the hashtag Jen look at me
I think she made up encouraging kids and
the arts to share their talents online
since they can't perform now what did
you play again was it uh was it horn do
you mean
sadly the sexy saxophone a flat Alto to
promote it she actually busted out her
own instrument to play happy birthday as
a hand washing song alongside the
late-night host
[Music]
wash your hands and don't touch your
feet
[Music]